yesterday we began the show by talking
about the many millionaire and
billionaire celebrities who are being
horrifically oppressed
in this country it's a big problem
michelle obama principal among them a
woman who says you know she fears
walking down the street
because of all the racist cops out there
prowling around she also says
she was in line for ice cream once and a
white woman cut in front of her
accidentally
these are the kinds of deprivations and
persecutions that she has suffered oprah
lebron james meghan markle
and others join her in the ranks of
extraordinarily wealthy and powerful
victims but i feel a little embarrassed
today because while
listing all of the most prominent and
profitable victims in america
today i somehow neglected to mention the
greatest of them all the man who will
surely take
center stage on the mount rushmore of
self-victimizing millionaire bratz
and that would be of course colin
kaepernick colin kaepernick a former nfl
bench writer who decided to start
protesting
injustice at exactly the moment when his
nfl career was going off the rails
interesting timing then when he failed
out of the league after a seat after a
season where he went
one in ten as a starter he started to uh
started a new career as a professional
activist that career has been
far more successful and profitable than
his playing career
by a large margin he's had deals with
netflix nike many other major companies
released his own shoe gotten a book deal
a movie deal
and all the while he's being hailed as a
martyr for the cause
i mean what cause exactly well that was
never made exactly
clear originally we were told that his
kneeling during the anthem was a protest
against police brutality
not against the flag itself or the
country but then a few years ago
nike released a shoe or tried to release
a shoe with an american flag on it
and kaepernick complained so he didn't
want he didn't want there to be a shoe
with a flag on it and they recalled the
shoe now apparently
i guess he does have a problem with the
flag itself
what could his problem possibly be i
mean how could he
hate a country that's made him rich and
famous beyond
the wildest dreams of normal people and
giving him all this wealth and fame
despite the fact that he's produced
nothing of value really
nothing at all and actually flunked out
of his chosen field
how is that possible well these are all
good questions and we have another
chance to think about these questions
now that kaepernick
is back in the news reading out from the
daily wired says as tim tebow awaits a
possible one-year contract to play for
the jacksonville jaguars
progressives on twitter have excoriated
the nfl for leaving former 49ers
quarterback colin kaepernick
out in the cold as daly wire reported on
monday ian rappaport of nfl insider
announced that
tebow stands on the cusp of signing with
the jacksonville jaguars and reuniting
with his former mentor
he's tweeted quote the jaguars are
planning to sign qb turn
tight end tim tebow to a one-year deal a
deal that could be official in next week
or so nothing done yet but he'll have a
chance
to make the team to reunite with his
mentor and college head coach urban
meyer so
it's a chance to uh make the team he's
not actually on the team yet
but back to us to the articles as
kaepernick fans many of whom feel the
nfl blackballed him in response to his
national anthem protest in the name of
black lives matter
did not welcome the news quote
interesting how the same people that are
praising tim tebow for his values
outside of football see colin
kaepernick's values as a distraction
that according to ahmed ali another one
says there's no way you can
tell me that tim tebow deserves to be on
a team as an unproven tight end who
hasn't played in nine years more than
colin kaepernick
there's just no way that's going to make
sense that according to david dennis jr
there was plenty more reactions along
those lines all from the usual suspects
including jameel hill and others of
course
cory booker a noted nfl analyst chimed
in as well here's what he said
people are saying you know it there's a
little white privilege going on here
you know tim tebow has a different
there's different standards for him
to cast a shadow on tim tebow in order
to
point out the injustice of colin
kaepernick i mean
that is uh it's wrong he was blackballed
uh and i don't need to push somebody
else down in order to
point that out so i just know that he's
gotten an
awful deal it's it's he is an
extraordinary athlete
uh who had his career sabotaged by
people
that were against him doing what some of
the greatest athletes of all times from
arthur ashton muhammad ali have done
which is speak out against injustice do
you think colin maybe should try a
different position or is that is it just
you think it's it's more than just a
position i think it has nothing to do
with him it has to do with the nfl and
the decisions that were made
just perfect there in that video uh
perfect timing as they're interviewing
cory booker
in nice looks like dc and
a guy jogs by wearing a mask just
absolutely perfect these lunatics these
psychos um anyway these comparisons are
all coming from people who either don't
understand the game of football probably
the case for cory booker or who are
pretending
not to understand tim tebow will be
attending training camp to try out for a
different position
where he will no doubt be a backup and
get paid the minimum salary or close to
it
so he just wants to play the game and
he's willing to do whatever it takes for
a shot at playing the game in contrast
colin kaepernick has shown no interest
in playing at any position
let alone let alone a less glamorous one
as a backup
for comparatively little money in fact
two years ago the nfl held a workout for
kaepernick
in the middle of the 2019 season 25
scouts attended
this was all unprecedented as far as i
know the nfl doesn't usually hold
personal workouts for aging backup
players
in the middle of the season or at any
other time of the year they certainly
didn't do that for tim tebow i could
tell you
but they did it for kaepernick because
he'd call them racist if they didn't
but as it turns out he'll call them
racist even if they do you're racist if
you do racist if you don't
that's how it goes with guys like
cabernet cap uh bailed on the workout
though and instead
held his own media event where he wore a
shirt comparing himself to a slave
making him the highest paid slave in
history we we must say
and he blasted the nfl and roger goodell
the commissioner it was all publicity
stunt
they held the workout for him he refused
to go to it and then did his own event
in front of in front of the cameras
where he was complaining about the nfl
is that what you do if you really want
to play for the nfl if you want a job in
the nfl
is that what you do they invited you to
the workout there are 25 scouts there
show up show them what you can do
demonstrate a little bit of
professionalism and humility
and you get an offer at least to try out
for a team
but he didn't want to actually play he
still doesn't he never did
he's a con man and a grifter an actor
playing a role and
we have to also say playing it pretty
damned well give him credit for that
but nfl head coaches they don't want
actors
on their sidelines they want players
colin kaepernick is not a player and
doesn't want to be one
he hasn't wanted to be one since he
discovered how much money there was to
be made
pretending to be an activist but there's
another difference too and this is
important
another difference between tebow and
kaepernick
the fans love tim tebow
almost everyone loves tim tebow lots of
people hate colin kaepernick
why is that if you're a very stupid
person
you've probably already shouted it's
racism
because of team tebow he's the white guy
that's why they like him
except that the nfl is full of beloved
black athletes
so it's obviously not that the key
difference or one of the key differences
is gratitude both tebow and kaepernick
have lived a blessed life
they're both wealthy and famous and uh
and
and this country has treated them
extraordinarily well
what people like about tim tebow is that
he seems to be aware of this fact and he
exudes gratitude and humility because of
it
he loves this country and he's grateful
for the opportunities that the country
has afforded him
this is an attractive quality among all
people
people root for that people like to be
around that kind of
attitude kaepernick on the other hand
is sullen spoiled ungrateful
this country has given him everything
but it's never enough
he always demands more not because he's
earned it but because
he feels entitled to it he's a
self-victimizing drama queen
a rich whiny entitled complainer now his
his fellow
his fellow rich whiny entitled
complainers in the media
they like that about him because they
can relate to it but it's not the kind
of thing that normal people respect or
want to root for
and it distresses normal people that
this attitude is so common
that there is so little gratitude in
this country
and it is especially absent among the
people who should be
the most displaying it
gratitude that is a a
virtue that's a quality that we're
losing in this country
and we need to regain
tim tebow versus colin kaepernick
perfect example as to why
well i hope you enjoyed that clip from
the matt wall show if you did go ahead
and hit that subscribe button right down
there so you can stay up to date on all
of our future content